Most of the contracts we have seen in this course are the product of verbal,
either oral or written agreements between the parties.
Today we're going to consider contracts that might exist without an explicit
agreement.
The 1969 case of Bailey versus west is often one of the first cases taught in a
contracts course because it touches on important principles of contract
formation.
We will use the case to introduce several important concepts,
including implied in fact contracts and cuase I contracts or contracts implied
in law.
These terms might sound like fancy legal ease for now,
but they will make sense very soon.
The defendant appellee in this case,
Richard West purchased a horse named Baskins folly from Doctor Strauss.
The defendant's trainers subsequently discovered that the horse was lame.
The trainer tried to send the horse back to Strauss,
but Strauss refused to accept it.
The horse,
uh,
deliver who's referred to in the opinion as one Kelly then under instruction
from the defendant's trainer that he should do whatever he wanted to do with the
horse,
but that he wouldn't be on any farm at defendant's expense delivered the horse
to plaintiff.
Appellant Bailey,
a plaintiff accepted the horse understanding that its ownership was disputed and
sent bills to both defendant and to Strauss before selling the horse.
After caring for it for four years,
defendant returned the bills unpaid with notations that he did not own the
horse.
There's something ironic in the plaintiff's name.
In Property Law,
a bailment is illegal relationship will wear a bay lore in trusts,
physical possession of personal property,
uh,
to another person who was called the Bailey.
So,
uh,
in this case,
Howard Bailey is a Bailey who was entrusted with the horse
and in this case,
the plaintiff sued to recover their reasonable value for services rendered in
caring for the horse.
The trial court awarded awarded plaintiff's costs for the first five months of
care as well as certain expenses for trimming the horses hooves.
Uh,
the trial court,
uh,
reason that because the supreme court in a separate disputed found that West
owned the Horse and oh doctor Strauss,
the purchase price,
that there was a contractual employee contract implied in fact to care for the
horse until West notified Bailey.
Otherwise,
the instant court in this case,
however,
reversed the trial court's finding of liability and instead found for the
defendant west.
Before we go on,
take a look at this question.
Why does the PA opinion use the phrase clearly erroneous when discussing the
[inaudible] contract claim?
Well,
this is a standard of review for factual issues.
Uh,
the clearly erroneous standard of review,
which is in contrast and distinct from the denovo standard for reviewing
questions of law.
And the appellate court should only set aside a factual finding of a trial court
if that finding is clearly erroneous.
Well,
so in this case there are two major issues.
First,
was there an implied in fact contract between the plaintiff and the defendant?
And second,
was there a quiz I contract or a contract implied in law between the plaintiff
and defendant?
Let's first take a look at whether an implied in fact contract exists and
implied.
In fact,
contract is a contract where the party's agreement is inferred from their
conduct rather than by explicit words.
If you go in a restaurant and the server asks you what will you have and you
respond,
give me a Pastrami on Rye.
Uh,
please.
do you have an explicit contract?
Well,
no.
Nobody promised anybody anything.
You never explicitly promise the waitress that you would pay.
You said,
give me something.
But as you already know,
the lack of an explicit agreement is not really relevant.
You're going to be on the hook to pay for the food that you ordered.
An eight,
because of the conduct of the overall circumstances by sitting down at a table
in a restaurant and ordering food off the menu that made you contractually
liable for an implied in fact contract.
It's implied by the facts of your conduct or the surrounding circumstances and
implied in fact,
contract has the same legal effect as an express contract,
express contracts or the contracts we've been studying.
In other cases,
the main difference is that the people use words and an express contract.
While an implied in fact contract people manifest their mutual assent by their
actions and their words,
uh,
for an implied in fact contract to exist.
Two conditions must be satisfied.
There must be one mutual agreement and two,
there must be an intent to promise.
In this case the court found these elements to be lacking and held.
There was no implied in fact contract.
The plaintiff's knew that the ownership of the horse was in dispute and sent
multiple bills,
uh,
to different people,
not knowing who was going to be responsible.
And therefore the plaintiff should have known that neither west North Strauss
had agreed to the transaction.
It's socially valuable to probe,
to promote mutual assent.
If we have mutual assent,
we have a revealed preference,
uh,
argument,
an inference that the contract is increasing the welfare of each of the parties
without mutual assent.
It's unclear whether value is created.
People will be forced into contracts that they did not want to enter.
The,
the difference here is if we can,
if we're confidence that both sides had agreed to the transaction,
we can infer by their conduct,
by their revealed preference for assenting to the contract that they,
that they're,
each of them are better off by entering.
But in a case like this where their conduct is not clear,
we can't make this revealed preference inference that value has been created
allowing for implied.
In fact,
contract seems to make a lot of sense.
Life would be a lot more inconvenient if,
say you had to sign a contract every time you went into a restaurant.
However,
you might wonder if the lack of explicit agreements presents other problems.
For instance,
does a party subjective intent matter?
Suppose you sit down at the restaurant but secretly harbored no intent to pay.
Does that let you out of the contract?
Well,
the answer is no.
Of course.
Generally when a settling disputes about contract formation rather than
subjective intent,
the law looks to the reasonableness of the other person's inferences if it's
reasonable for the waitress to infer that you implicitly promised to pay when
you ordered the sandwich.
The same applies to express contracts,
which refers to the verbal or written agreements that we've been studying in
these other cases.
Thus,
if I say,
I'll sell you my watch for $400 and you say,
I accept your honest,
but uncommunicated belief that there is no contract until a writing assigned
will be irrelevant.
The fact that you manifested and intent to contract,
it's reasonable for me to hear what you said as entering into contract.
That's going to be enough for courts.
Here's a quiz for you in Bailey,
the West.
If the court had used the reasonableness of the listeners expectation standard,
should the plaintiff have prevailed?
No,
it wasn't reasonable for Bailey to think that he had an agreement to board the
horse.
Bailey didn't even know with whom he was contracting and he again,
he sent bills to both west and Strauss.
There's nothing that Bailey heard that would've made it reasonable for him to
think that he had entered into a contract is assumption that he was to take care
of this horse was the plaintiff had reason to know that there was no mutual
assent.
The defendant neither said nor did anything to create reasonable expectations or
from which a promise to pay might be implied.
So even if the plaintiff cannot prevail on his first claim that there was an
implied in fact contract,
he still has another argument that there was a quiz I contract or a contract
implied in law cuase I contracts are not true contracts.
They are obligations imposed by the law in in cases where a contract should have
existed where promises should have been made but no actual or implied promises
actually happened.
Uh,
the main goal of Quasar by contract as a separate cause of action is to remedy
the possibility of unjust enrichment,
namely one party getting a significant benefit without having to pay for it,
which leads to an inequitable result.
Quayside contracts or also known as implied in law contracts,
constructive contracts,
sometimes referred to as unjust enrichment causes of actions.
Uh,
so don't be confused if you hear these different terms.
They all mean something close to the same thing.
They are all equitable causes of action,
which like many things in equity are less rule like,
and have fuzzier elements and probabilistic legal outcomes for a quasar contract
to exist.
The court states that,
uh,
that there are three conditions which must be satisfied.
First,
there must be a benefit conferred upon the defendant.
Second,
the defendant must appreciate the benefit.
In other words,
the defendant must feel the benefit.
Uh,
and finally it would be an equitable for the defendant to retain the benefit
without making a payment to the plant to the plaintiff.
In this case,
the court found that know cuase I contract existed.
The defendant never accepted the benefit conferred by the plaintiff,
mainly the this raising or caring for the horse.
The court especially emphasize the importance of respecting individual autonomy
in contracts.
Saying,
quote,
a person is not required to deal with another unless he desires to and
ordinarily a person should not be required to become an obliger unless he so
desires.
Another way to think about the issue is that the plaintiff was acting as a
volunteer.
You are officiously conferring a benefit if you do it expecting payment without
giving the pay or the chance to decline.
This affects the third factor,
acceptance and retention of the benefit by the defendant.
The court found that the plaintiff was a mirror volunteer and hence unreasonable
and conferring the benefit which the defendant clearly did not want or at least
did not clearly want.
All alternative conditions have also been proposed for thinking about what is it
cuase I contract.
For instance,
I hear by propose the would have,
couldn't have standard to explain quayside contract liability to my mind cuase I
contract liability is more likely to lie if the plaintiff can show that the
defendant would have been willing to contract to pay for the benefit that the
defendant,
uh,
that was conferred on the defendant but that the defendant couldn't enter into
an express or implied in fact contract.
The classic example of Xy contract liability can turn concerns the pedestrian
who was hit by a car and his line unconscious in the street.
A pastor by provides medical assistance,
saves the pedestrians life and then sues for quite shy contractual damages.
The would have,
couldn't have elements are clearly present.
The pedestrian would have been willing to contract to pay for his life being
saved.
But the passer by has a pretty good excuse for not securing an explicit
agreement since the pedestrian was passed out at the time,
uh,
that this benefit was conferred.
Bailey and contrast doesn't have any good excuse for not securing a more
explicit agreement.
Uh,
we have just been exposed to a lot of new and important legal terms.
Let's take some time to review them.
Number one and express contract is a contract that was created with the party's
verbal agreement on the promises and performances.
These are contracts where the agreement was explicitly stated on paper or
orally.
And then number two,
an implied in fact contract is a contract in which the agreement is inferred by
the party's conduct ordering food at a restaurant or going for a doctor's
appointment or often examples of implied in fact contracts.
And then finally,
uh,
cuase I contract or a contract implied in law is not a true contract.
It's not one where people made explicit or implicit exchange of promises.
Instead,
it's an obligation imposed by the law to prevent unjust enrichment.
It's also called,
this has an implied in law contract or a constructive contract.
There doesn't have to be mutual agreement for cuase I contract.
Now that we've reviewed these terms,
you're ready for an important.
So what's the difference between an implied in fact contract and equate cy
contract?
Well implied in fact,
contracts like express contracts involved chosen obligations,
their obligations that the people opted into by their actions or words.
In contrast,
cuase I contracts involve obligations that are not mutually chosen.
They're not mutually assented to there.
Instead implied in law chosen by the courts to emulate the deals that the
parties would have agreed to if they had had the chance.
Here are some interesting parting thoughts and questions.
Number one,
suppose west personally delivered basket folly to Bailey's farm,
but nothing was specifically said about Bailey caring for the horse or West's
paying for that care.
Would West be liable then?
Well,
the answer is that West would probably be liable on the finding that they had an
implied in fact contract.
As we discussed earlier,
this pattern of conduct,
this behavior seems to suggest mutual assent and an intent from both parties to
be contractually bound for the care of the horse.
Number two.
What if Bailey found Baskins folly collapsed alongside the highway,
took the horse in and cared for the horse and thereafter sought out west for a
payment with west be responsible for Bailey for the care given to the horse?
And if so,
on what theory?
Well,
the answer there is Westwood probably be liable on a quiz I contractual claim or
at least it would be arguable.
In that case,
Bailey conferred a measure of a measurable benefit on West who was the owner of
the horse and Bailey would have a good excuse for not obtaining explicit
agreement in advance because the horse was in immediate need of care.
And finally,
if West gets to keep the horse afterwards,
then there's a good argument that there is unjust in re Richmond West
essentially got free medical treatment for the horse without having to pay for
it.
And,
and what should we think about what happened to the proceeds of the horses sale?
They seem to have been retained by the plaintiff.
So even under the plaintiff's theory of the case,
these some should have offset the amount owed by the defendant.
This case might've turned out differently if Bailey had returned the horse to
west after caring for it and West had sold the horse.
Today we have examined the case that introduced us to the difference between
three major types of contracts,
explicit contracts,
which are formed by express agreement,
implied in fact contracts which are formed by inference of the party's con duct.
And finally cuase I contracts where there is no mutual assent and uh,
exchange of promises,
but benefit is conferred by one party on another party.
And that receiving party is liable as a matter of law to pay the,
uh,
for that benefit.
And we've also learned that implied in fact,
contracts require a mutual agreement and intend to promise cuase ag contracts do
not require a mutual agreement.
Instead,
there must be a benefit that is non officiously conferred on another party and
that party must appreciate the benefit and retain it.